okay so they're the same recipe but one
has all local ingredients the other
one's all store-bought ingredients local
ingredients what's a local ingredient Oh
from the farmers market at Union Square
this is fresh yes from today and hi I'm
Merle and today we're gonna be doing a
locally sourced versus store-bought
apple pie challenge so originally I was
just gonna buy a premade store-bought
apple pie but then I looked at the
ingredients on the box and like I don't
even know what a lot of these are to be
honest with you we've got corn syrup
palm and or soybean oil Malto dextran
what the hell is dextran sodium prop POA
night I don't know what this stuff is so
we're not gonna do that instead I'm
going to have one recipe that's gonna be
exactly the same the only difference is
gonna be that in one pie almost all of
the ingredients will be locally sourced
and in the other pie all of them will be
store-bought and then at the end we're
gonna have a few people taste test to
see if they can taste the difference
between locally sourced and store-bought
all right let's get cooking first thing
we're gonna do is add the flour and the
salt into it like a medium-sized bowl
and just mix it with a fork until it's
nicely combined so the great thing about
this farm that I bought this flour from
is that they focus heavily on
sustainability so by buying their
products I'm directly supporting that
cause then I'm gonna add in the cubed
butter and just try to break it up
really nicely with the fork you want the
lumps to be like the size of small peas
the butter we have today is from a dairy
farm in Pennsylvania you might be
noticing that the color is a little more
yellow than some of the sticks you see
in the store the reason for that is
because of what the cow eats
pasture-raised cows are given a lot of
fresh grass which contributes to this
really pretty color then gradually you
want to add in the ice water while
you're mixing the dough eventually the
dough is going to come together you may
not need all the water but if the dough
is too dry then you can add more you
just want to make sure the dough isn't
very sticky or tacky so now I'm just
going to work the dough together nicely
until I can get it into a smooth ball
and then
with cling wrap and refrigerate it for
both recipes we're gonna be using granny
smith apples these are kind of like the
apple of apple pies the thing that you
can notice right away between the
store-bought and the locally source is
the way they look the store-bought one
is a bit shinier and the reason for that
is because most store-bought apples
actually have a wax coating on them this
is to help them last longer
your average store-bought Apple could be
anywhere from five months to even a year
old
that doesn't necessarily affect the
taste but I guess we will do the judge
of that
in a little while with the locally
sourced one you'll notice they're not
entirely green the reason for this is
because well we're in the Northeast so
the colder temperatures give them like a
little red blush which is I think kind
of adorable you're probably wondering
why should I care the store-bought Apple
has traveled 2,500 miles from Washington
State to New York State that requires a
lot of energy fuel and extra time and of
course the apples not going to be as
fresh meanwhile the locally sourced
apple has come just under 100 miles from
upstate New York okay next we're gonna
peel the apples then core and slice them
in a bowl you're gonna toss together the
apples with some sugar flour salt nutmeg
cinnamon and a little bit of lemon juice
we did our best to make sure all of our
ingredients were local but with things
like cinnamon sugar and salt it's not
always possible depending on where you
live all right so you're gonna mix those
up until they're evenly combined and
refrigerate those as well
pre-heat your oven to around 375 degrees
Fahrenheit cut your pie dough in half
and roll out both halves until they're
both round and about 1/8 of an inch
thick an easy way to move your dough is
to roll it right up onto your rolling
pin and then unroll it onto your pie
dish
then you're gonna pour in your apple
filling and Pat it down so it's even
then just roll the other half of the
dough on top and trim the extra dough
from the edges pinch the edges to create
a nice little crimp effect and make sure
that all the edges are steel together
cut four slits into the top of the pie
to create a nice little vent for a while
it's baking now you just want to brush
your pie with the egg wash even for the
egg wash on this pie we got locally
sourced eggs these chickens were pasture
raised which means they get to eat
grass and bugs and run around and be
happy and therefore they produce more
nutritional and colorful eggs
now you're just want to sprinkle a
little bit of sugar on top bake your pie
for 50 to 60 minutes you'll know it's
ready when the crust is nice and golden
brown so we've got our store bought
version and we have our locally sourced
version they're both looking very
beautiful so I'm just gonna cut these up
and then we're gonna get some taste
testers in here to see the pink
I just gotta say this crust looks
unbelievable it looks really really
delicious so my prediction is this I'm I
think that possibly the store-bought one
might taste a bit more familiar to
people so I'm not sure I hope they like
the locally sourced one but we're gonna
have to just find out
[Music]
it has a weird consistency it's a lot
it's it's it's like it's sweet but it's
good but it's it's very there's a lot of
stuff inside too sweet for me I need a
glass of milk it's more of like a it's
like a pudding it's like a pudding pie I
mean I have to try the second one before
I can give you any serious opinions I
hate this pipe I like this one the crust
is perfect the apples are really like
tight those are some tight apples this
one I can already tell make it looks
more flaky
it's like crunchy and it's not as sweet
the apples are still crunchy yeah which
is actually kind of nice okay so if you
had to pick which one do you like better
absolutely like this pie better okay
this was the locally sourced one so you
like did good for the world by liking
that behind nice this crust for me is
like the bond and I would probably guess
that this is the one that's made with
locally sourced ingredients ding ding
ding yeah you got it this one just feels
amazing the whole time so awesome
someone's the all locally sourced
ingredients one can you teach me how to
make it because then I want to go and
shop at a store cos all I can do is this
for now
Wow okay I genuinely thought that a lot
of people were gonna pick the
store-bought slice I was a little bit
worried I'm not gonna lie to you but I'm
really happy to see that they could
actually taste the difference in the
crust because of that butter and I think
it just goes to show that when you do
invest a little bit in local ingredients
you're not only supporting a great cause
you're also providing yourself with that
extra taste and like that extra kick
that you can give to any dish yo I
actually I didn't know that like local
food was a thing and it tastes a lot
better so
[Music]